when you were a little kid yeah uh you
went around singing you know the
national anthem and yeah the national
anthem yeah like that was your career
for a while
yes i was very driven and your mom would
take these uh
audition tapes of you singing the
national anthem and bring them to the
appropriate people and then like bake a
pie for them too
she would make cookies she was way into
it she was well she was she knew that i
was way into it so she tried to just put
it over the edge why focus on the
national anthem as a singer was that
like a niche that
could propel you because this is an
amazing career story
i
went to an orlando magic game i grew up
in orlando and i saw a little girl my
age sing it and that's what sparked the
idea for me i had no idea before that
that was a possibility yeah you were
like hey wait a second if i can do that
if i sing the national anthem and then
what do you do you go home and and like
just practice the national anthem
and you know every word of it have you
ever screwed up the national anthem have
you ever forgotten the words it's been a
minute since i've i've done it um but i
know that was always my biggest fear
though is it the hardest song in the
world to sing 100 why is it so hard i
think the range it's like a full octave
the song and would you sing it acapella
or would you sing it with a with a i'd
sing it when acapella i'd like walk out
with my little pitch pipe
and then you start did word get out that
you were a great singer of the national
anthem i think word got out that this
quasi-cute 12-year-old like could get
through the national anthem so i sang it
for the orlando magic and then i sort of
became like went on the national the
national anthem circuit in orlando and i
sang for the roller hockey team the ice
hockey team the arena football team
anything that sort of played in the
arena there and what is amazing to me is
you're doing the national anthem and
some dude hears you yes and he says
hey if you could pony up some money for
recording studio time yeah
i'll um i'll i want to make records with
you or we'll make a demo tape yeah i
wrote some original songs did you expect
superstardom out of this because because
but but there's so much commotion going
on around a young girl
i would think in your mind you're like
oh my god this is all happening and you
know how they say oh you know it takes
years on the road before you get a
record contract you got to work at your
[ __ ] boom one recording session and
you're getting signed absolutely
it was
unfathomable i'm glad it happened to me
when i was young because it's
you're clueless and you're also fearless
it's the perfect combination so i was
like i don't know what i'm doing but i'm
ready you know and so when uh when you
meet with this record company guy and
like you say you know you're a girl
who's still going to high school what
grade were you with you're probably 9th
grade ninth grade freshman didn't you
drop out of school in ninth grade
because you had to go on tour i yeah i
started extended studies i was
homeschooled did you do you have a high
school diploma i do oh you do yeah a ged
ged yeah did you start to feel to it
like it was too much pressure when the
singing thing happens and here you're
like a teenage pop star
uh they're banking on you to become the
next britney spears or christina
aguilera is it an intense pressure on
you no no no i didn't feel that you
didn't feel like oh my god my first
album's coming out and if i don't make
it i suck i was excited but
i felt like the machine was going and
it's such a clip that i just i was in it
i mean imagine being signed to a record
contract at 14 years old to epic records
like that is insane did they pay you a
decent amount of money it was a shitty
contract it was yeah but you don't care
no no way i remember my parents when i
signed the deal
they let me they gave me a thousand
dollars cash to go to the mall and it
was like
my head exploded i was so excited like
i've never seen so much money but you
must have been the talk of your local
neighborhood i mean that's a big deal
nobody knew that i sang though i kept it
really quiet really so i left school and
i remember friends telling me that they
would call my name after um like enroll
right after the christmas break they're
like no no she left at what age do you
start to say i want to be an actress
well i grew up doing musical theater so
i always wanted to act and what was the
first big role that um i had a small
role principle
diary yeah that's with anne hathaway
good actress amazing and were you were
you shocked that that movie made so much
money
no i mean the thing was a mega hit i i
wasn't shocked it was gary marshall and
julie andrews and it was beautiful and
yeah were you intimidated at all being
on a movie like that
not really again that young clueless
fearless side takes over
gee yeah
yeah unbelievable career